this is some extra discussion following
our main video about Phil's homemade
radio right well we've got so over here
we have this wonderful crystal radio now
we've covered a lot of the physics but
one thing we didn't really focus on
because there's an awful lot even though
this is just a few components this is
there's an incredible amount of physics
and electronics going on in this the
core of this as well as the diode is
what's called a tuned circuit so when I
adjust this so nothing now what I'm
doing is I'm changing the capacitance
and that's changing what's called the
resonant frequency of this circuit the
frequency at which its most sensitive
resonance is absolutely crucial across
all physics and all engineering its
first second third year or
undergraduates pulse graduates right
across the board it crops up time and
time again from everything from pushing
somebody on a swing or a mass on a
spring I like this multi bump on up and
down at a particular rate at its natural
or resonant frequency and that's set in
this case by the stiffness of the spring
and the mass of the monkey it's a very
simple equation similarly here what
we're doing is we're choosing a
particular frequency out of a range of
frequencies this particular station
broadcasts that I think something like
I've got this wrong absolute radio I
apologize but it's something like 1.2
megahertz so 1.2 million times a second
radio wave is moving back and forth but
this way this wire by itself isn't just
picking up that signal it's picking up
all the other signals as well so what
you need to do is is to narrow in and
get that frequency which is what was
happening earlier wonderfully we've got
a mechanical we can see this idea of
resonance really straightforward this is
a very simple setup we've got a bar of
rule or basically and it also has its
own natural frequency we're actually
going to drive it mechanically there's a
solenoid here and there's a magnet so
we're just driving it back and forth
with a magnet and to monitor the motion
we could look at this but we're gonna do
something even nicer which is we've got
a laser pointer that's quite neat
because what we have is something that's
going to tell us just how much this is
vibrating so what's happening is the
laser going down and there's a little
more and then just bouncing off okay at
the moment you can see it's bobbing up
and down
but not very much no so we're at 4 Hertz
4.4 Hertz Brady's so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna turn the frequency up
notice I'm not driving at the amplitude
steers the same all I'm changing is the
frequency this is really important and
ok so it's going up going up and of
course the frequency is going up so it's
bouncing around a little bit more 12
Hertz 14 Hertz 15 Hertz okay so we're
getting some but not much 16 17 18 now a
little bit more but not much still so
that's not much more than when we were
at 4 Hertz that's off resonance right so
we haven't hit the natural frequency
remember we have the monkey and the blue
holitzer so what I'm gonna do is find a
natural frequency so you're building up
oh yeah right so we're at resonant
frequency right now if we go the other
side why is that things suddenly gone
yeah I'm going crazy because what you've
done is exactly what the radio circuit
it's you driving it with the right
frequency it's got its own natural
frequency just as the monkey on this
thing or any mass on a spring has its
own natural frequency this has its own
natural frequency and now you're driving
it at that natural frequency and what is
that very concept and our frequency is
about 25 Hertz the difference is is when
you're away from that frequency you
don't get much energy transfer so it's
still vibrating but when you hit that
residence with resonant frequency that's
where you got a lot of energy transfer
into it and it actually acts as a filter
because if we go above that when I was
33 Hertz
well now with the other side and it's
day enough and you can see that it's
reduced almost to what it was when we
were at 18 Hertz so you're saying when
you put in the correct natural resonance
frequency energy transfer like does that
mean it's kind of like to use a term you
probably won't like it's almost like the
stars of aligned and this is like yeah
the way all my structure works and my
length and my what I made of this is
just the perfect thing for everything
precisely now you can do this experiment
without driving it this the ruler its
resonant frequency depends on its length
so if I make this long relatively low
resonant frequency if I make it short
higher resonant frequency can even hear
the note changing resident frequencies
going down and it's so if I took this
now when I drove it at that frequency I
get a lot of energy transfer and you
get this big response that's what's
happening here but it gets better so we
can draw a parallel between what's here
and what's here so here we've got a mass
and we've got some friction and that's
you know friction due to the rod itself
but also with the air and we're driving
it with this and what we also have is
some stiffness because the robots got
some stiffness over here we've got
inductance capacitance it's being driven
by this by the radio waves and what's
absolutely remarkable is that the
inductance here if we write down
equations I'm not going to do that don't
worry Brady but if you write down the
equations what we find is that we can do
a one-to-one mapping of inductance to
mass capacitance to spring constant to
stiffness also in terms of the driving
force in this case it's a mechanical
driving force in this case it's an
electrical driving force and the
equation that the differential equation
you write down is identical and the
solutions are identical so that's where
you see resonance here and you also see
residents here at different frequencies
but it's the same phenomenon so that
moment when you got that bar to jump up
and down like crazy there is the same as
the moment when you got absolute radio
there are two perfect white and then
scale it or we can do what we're doing
here and we can listen to it
[Music]